[Music]
let the last
[Music]
anyway
sophie wow
oh you look you look amazing so do you
see i saw you outside coming down the
stairs you've grown
we've been whoa you've really grown last
time we saw each other we were like
10. no it wasn't and you've grown too
like upwards at
uni a career big house with a big
kitchen
family school fees dinner parties
dead car
i know no i don't know
[Music]
because you came along and messed it all
up
[Music]
look at this place is this us now
[Music]
right now yeah
[Music]
it's this in fact this might be the best
bit
do you really think this could be the
best fit
maybe
we should make the most of it then yeah
yeah
well what are you doing come on what are
you doing
no no no let's go no no okay please sit
down
come on hello please are you gonna leave
me standing here
[Music]
live rooms here
[Music]
i didn't say that
[Music]
so what's stopping you
are you scared of me soldier boy
[Music]
calum yeah
imagine if we got out of here
i mean really out of here yeah
out of albion africa even just like that
yeah because it's so easy
what would we do in africa does it
matter
it's easier there for people like us
we'd be left alone kevin that's gotta
count for something
things aren't really changing
we're just two people against millions
of mr jeremies
given up so easily
why not
think about it yeah
yeah if we do move to africa though
does that mean i finally get to
rokodashiki no
[Laughter]
i'm actually kind of glad you said no
i'm just sick and tired of it
i'm not failure
i'm not afraid you're not you're not
you're having me you're not you're not
look at me look at me
look at me
[Music]
it's not for nothing
[Music]
um
[Music]
stop stop
[Music]
uh
uh
i missed you
same i was
really hurt when you left me and
look um there's something i need to tell
you
just what no no no no no no no
please no i need
the kind of that i knew was full of love
and not hate he wanted to make things
better
not threaten lives
sephie it's me yummy
i'm ready i want you
i don't know which is the greater
punishment
to take your life or to have you spend
the rest of your days in the 12x8
thinking about your mistake
[Music]
no stephanie what are you doing
i'm trying to protect you i'm trying to
protect you
you're threatening my entire world
[Music]
what next but keep on running
keep on hiding they'll kill you
if they catch us so we don't get caught
[Music]
[Music]
about
[Music]
me
you